So, uh, it's great to reconnect.
I got to meet you and your beautiful family in the magical town of yellow
Springs,
Ohio this summer as part of freaking
camp Chappelle, it was amazing. I've got a t-shirt,
uh, I've got memories.
They really, it was like a summer camp.
I ended up, I ended up going pretty crazy there. I bought them,
I bought a scooter and then three other motorcycles.
And so somebody had an accident on my moped.
Like they on my motorcycle and they hurt themselves pretty badly,
like their crack, their shoulder and stuff.
Wait, so that,
that happened before I got on Michelle's moped and was like running around.
So everybody was looking at you like, Oh,
that's why everyone was scared shitless, because I was like, guys,
I'm an adult male. Like this isn't like a, you know,
freaking Harley or something like it's right.
I think next thing you know,
parking parking a scooter can fracture to your shoulders. I still to this day,
don't know how he did it, but you know, I'm glad he's okay, Matthew, I'm sorry.
I love you. I hope you're well, yeah.
Shout out to you, Matthew. Hope your shoulders are all right.
I'm so glad that at least some people were documenting parts of the camp
experience. Cause I, you know,
I know that that someone was working on a project for it. Uh,
and I can see exactly how you got addicted to buying two wheeled vehicles there.
Cause it's summer, it's beautiful. You're just roaming around. Uh,
and so I see why he didn't stop at the moped.
I defend you Mo I defend you and your three motorcycles, uh, on top of it.
I appreciate it. I needed that. You know,
I was going really smart cause I was like, yeah,
I haven't written motorcycles at least 12 years.
So let's get like a 120 CC little scoot situation,
put a boom box. It's almost bigger than the tires,
scooter itself on the back of it. Enjoy these, you know, cinematic.
Beautiful, gorgeous. You go there. Like, you know,
you just look out it's like Americana,
Corrine feels like such a, it was gorgeous.
Pretend like I'm an American pickers. I would constantly like stop.
And she's like, Oh, what does this item is? Santiq from the forties.
It was very nice. Like stop at a rusted filled farm or something like,
and I would attempt to buy some of their junk that's in the yard.
That's like one of my favorite past times when I was just trying to decompress,
it was so much fun. It was so much fun.
So how did your wife feel about the purchases?
This is a common question. More common,
more common than I ever thought it would be. Yeah. It's just like, I don't,
I didn't really tell.
Her.
I just did it. I was very smart about it though.
It was like a traditional Arab trader. I was like, I don't know. You know,
I was really like checking out the market. One of the.
Honey, I bought the death machine smart.
I was a savvy death machine buyer.
She divorced me. You know, that's how, that's how this all works. You know?
Uh, it's a very clear progression. Uh, you know that, that's why they have that,
uh, divorce lawyer office attached to the motorcycle dealer.
I bet there's a few of them, dude. This is.
A billion dollar business idea. That's why, uh,
I'm the entrepreneur, I've got a vision. I,
you can attach all sorts of midlife crises services to the
motorcycle dealership. It's like what? You're here buying a bike.
You like these brand new overprice sunglasses that make you look 30 years
younger. That's how I justified my purchases. And like sunglasses. I have a,
you know,
you can't just buy regular sunglasses where else you just destroy them,
throw them out. You won't respect them.
You have to buy something of value that you have to care for them.
Especially if they have like resale value as well. Like, Oh no,
I can't lose these. Where are these? It makes you way more conscious of them.
I think to me, there's like a threshold where something becomes real and uh,
it's reality often is commensurate to whatever you paid for it. You know,
it's like, if you buy like $5 sunglasses, they're not real.
You can like lose them, sit on them. Like no one cares.
But then as soon as you break through a certain investment threshold, uh,
then all of a sudden it's like, okay,
this is an actual item of mine that I associate with myself.
And it says something about me and I take pride in or whatever it is.
What is that threshold for me? When does something become real?
When does it become.
Come real?
It doesn't exist. Otherwise it's garbage. So.
So I'm in Atlanta, Georgia. I don't know, like I'm,
I'm campaigning for the special Senate candidate that's and I was
getting some food, my family's on those curbside pickup things.
And so I stopped to park the car. There's an automated reader. Uh,
and I was like, I don't know how long it's gonna take me to pick up this food.
So I stick the credit card in the reader and I'm just jamming in like add time,
add time, add time. Because like, I was like, I don't,
I don't want to calculate.
Like, like, like that.
Twenty-five set per eight minute threshold.
I don't want to like cut it that close. Cause like you,
who knows how long that like some of these, these places take. So like that,
that parking experience was like below my reality threshold. I was just like,
like let's just make it so that, um,
I'm not going to have to deal with this for a minute.
It's one reason I became so passionate about universal basic income. I mean,
there are a lot of reasons, but uh, just like,
w we're we're now such a society of folks who are making that time, money,
trade off all of the time. Uh, and I still do it obviously. Um,
though now the threshold has to be higher for me to say like, okay,
it's going to be worth my cycles to try and save that quarter or whatever it is
when I was a kid growing up, the child of immigrants in this country,
like a quarter was precious and I would go to the arcade and then play it and
then just try and win for as long as possible.
It's like you had to like stretch the value of that quarter to a point where,
uh, you know, like you could entertain yourself all day.
Ideally that street fighter game at the Cornerstore before high school or after
high school was like the one, you know, that's, that's the game.
If you can just make that quarter, keep that. And that was it. That.
Was like our test of value as like a teenager. It's like,
if you can win and then it became, not only can you win,
but can you win with an obscure character? It's like,
it's not enough to be good at view or guile and defend your quarter.
But then eventually when you're like, I'm just going to screw around.
I'm just going to choose blocks.
[Inaudible] Oh my God never knew how to play with that guy.
And then there'd be like this.
From like the people being like, used to like blog it's like,
it was like a real expression of, of like confidence or cockiness.
The ultimate cockiness was the Holocene, which is now that I reflect on it,
a somewhat racist portrayal of like a Hindu warrior.
[Inaudible] it just like sat there for a second. Now that I think about it,
just like maybe it was a racist, just seeing this kid,
like I saw the kid in you, like, now that I think about it, maybe,
maybe I shouldn't have played with that care.
Awful as a character, you know, like he was like the shirt,
the closest thing to a sure loss.
It was if you played with that guy.
Uh, it could be that Mo and I are somewhat dating ourselves.
It seems like you and I came of age around the same time,
but I feel like even the kids know, street fighter, I hope it's a turtle.
I hope it's one of those things.
He was playing a street fighter and mortal combat just over Thanksgiving. Nice.
Yes. But it was like, wow. Oh,
this is the mortal Kombat y'all are growing up with,
is it much better than ours so much better?
The graphics are INSEAD arguable? No, it depends.
I actually liked the classic. I mean, just seeing what they're dealing with.
I mean, seeing the graphics, I kind of miss the dodgy graphics and uh,
you know, and, and seeing the pit of death, you know,
like it's a little bit different than a little bit more group,
like really gruesome. Actually.
I am definitely old enough now where I look back on certain things as like the
standard or the golden years, you know what I mean? Like that, like, um,
nineties video games, uh, eighties and nineties music, like it comes on,
I'm like, Oh, it doesn't make no, they don't make this. Like they used to.
You reminded me of a joke, uh, uh, an amazing comedian, uh,
Jack Mayberry. He's about to give a ride around, uh, uh, with somebody old.
They're always tell you where things didn't use to be, you know,
you just be sitting there going okay, that there,
it wasn't there all the way from there all the way to over there that wasn't
there either. Hey, look at that, that wasn't there.
That wasn't there from all the way from there and all the way into it.
Wasn't there. Hell it was hell, it was just dark. It's not an out here,
you know, it's just so fast what you reminded me of right now.
And that's actually a reasonable summation of what's gone wrong with the
country, which is that it really is a, Hey,
we need to change things versus no stay the same, uh,
like have the same rules for ever. Uh,
and then we don't really have the capacity to actually change some of these
institutions, explain that for a lot of people are upset over the fact that, uh,
the electoral college and the popular vote aren't lining up terribly well. Um,
so you have folks who want to get rid of the electoral college.
Uh, but in order to get rid of the electoral college,
you need a super majority of States to get on board with that.
And like there's zero chance that Kansas and Nebraska are going to be like,
you're right. Like we shouldn't have this much say.
So it's one of those things.
Where you look at and be like, look, this is not changing in the way that, uh,
some people are arguing in any realistic fashion,
as long as you have that standard. There,
there are a lot of things that right now we're having a trouble we're having
trouble shifting because there's really no consensus or no
governing majority. Uh, and it's something that makes me very sad.
It's why I'm in Georgia honestly, is that, uh,
I hoped that we would have a government that could actually
address some of the big problems coming into 2021,
cause we've got major problems. Uh,
and instead it looks like we're going to struggle with a degree of
gridlock and dysfunction for the foreseeable. Uh, and,
and so you have this framework that set up that that says what you can do
and you can't change it unless you had let's, let's call it a super majority.
Let's call it 60 senators or whatever it is in the current rules. Uh, and,
and so the frustration is setting in on both sides.
We're having increasingly incoherent conversations about it. Uh,
and it makes me very sad. It makes me very sad too. Like I,
I told you in the beginning of this conversation, I mean,
you were the first campaign.
Than I ever vote. I mean, like, not only did I want to vote for you,
but I contributed too. Thank you. Yes. Thank you for listening in.
I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.